there is so much i want to ask because
there's so much going on i'm using the
word so much because
i am so so so proud of you as a mother
to see you grow up the way you are is is
such a proud moment for all of us so
thank you
yeah and mom you just you've done a
great job let's just say
all right
first thing first dancing with the stars
every performance was phenomenal it was
emotional and then you do born this way
it was epic i mean what does that song
represent to you and what does lady gaga
mean to you i mean born this way i feel
like a piece of me when i learned really
truly what the lyrics said yeah was like
oh
wait it's okay it's okay to be gay um so
i feel like it was it was a moment for
me with that song gaga
is somebody who is just herself
gaga somebody who i have never met
before who i don't personally know at
all but who i trust which is weird and
scary but i just feel like she's a
genuine person and i really appreciate
that and i love what she stands for and
what she stands about and so i i think
choosing to do that song in the stars
finale you know we start
thinking of what you would do for the
finale like five weeks into the season
like you start thinking about it
immediately because
you never know but you want to be
prepared if it does come and so you
start thinking about what you want to do
for your freestyle getting creative and
we tossed out a bunch of ideas jen and i
did my mom had some ideas like we we
threw out everything under the sun
and then one day i was like
why are we beating around the bush i was
like born this way i was like it is
absolutely perfect it's what we stand
for
and then a few days later i called jenna
and i was like all right
i was like here's my pitch and i was
like and chorus
dance with boys girls dance with girls
and she was like
sold and i was like
great so we had our thing we had what
was going to be and we were just we're
so excited and all we wanted to do then
was make it to the finale so we could do
that you know jojo use the word trust
and i think that's what a lot of people
feel in you and
you really have grown up in a way that a
lot of us are watching and have you now
under now do you understand the power of
your voice and your platform
it's interesting because
i don't
i mean i do but i don't i think
something that i really realized about
myself in the last 10 weeks is that
i grew up and i'm really lucky that
it was during dancing with the stars and
that it was live yeah because i feel
like a lot of times for me i have to do
a project and keep it a secret
and i feel like being able to age up on
a live show while it's naturally
happening it like it felt so right you
can't even make it up
um
i mean i think i know the reach that i
have and i see numbers i love numbers
and i see them and i know them
but
there's something about
just
feeling things from the world and i get
that feeling almost every day but it's
i never
fully realize
how many people there are that are out
there that are sewing eaters that are
supporters i mean it's
wild yeah and mom jess when you look at
her i mean i'm a mom of two girls and
that's why it's so beautiful to see the
bond between you two to see what she's
saying to see her in this moment what
does that mean to you as a mom
it's always
funny to me honestly that she doesn't
know her reach and who she is when i
tell her sometimes i have to remind her
who she is and like it's okay and i just
i love that she's still just like little
jojo siwa in her heart you know like
yeah a lot of times i'm like i'm just a
loser and
you don't know who you are and i'm like
it showed me like this doesn't look cool
i'm like you don't understand people
look to you what's cool like you decide
what's cool and what's not cool and she
just doesn't know which is cool you know
super humble and it's genuine and i love
that i love that and i love the fact
that you guys are partnered in a
different way with a brand new show
yeah it's like my dream come true to
work with her again
and it's true because you had to give up
your studio and because of dance moms
and here you are with 11 you girls i
mean this must be a dream come true for
you it's so fun and it's fun because
they're young
and they're excited and it's all new to
them and we have so much experience now
that we can just guide them the way that
we feel is right for them and it's
amazing to just be doing it again and
the kids are just incredible
and they're
so funny and just so in love with life
and so happy with what they're doing
right now one of the little girls um
brooklyn who just got her episode of the
show just came out where she made it a
part of the of the girl group xmg pop
uh which is so exciting for her she
called me
like an hour ago and i was like that's
strange why is brooklyn calling me then
it hung up and then she called me again
and i was like okay i was like what's up
brooklyn i answered and she was like hey
what's your mom's favorite scent
and i was like
i was like all right like they're just
so funny and i asked them
what makes you sad in that same little
girl brooklyn she said but my cheese on
my nachos is cold i was like that's
right that's right yes
and jojo you not only are you helping
with the dancing you're also mentoring
these girls what do you want to instill
in these 11 girls who are just looking
forward to stardom in the future
you know it's interesting because i
realized doing dancing with the stars
what i am to those kids
they are to me what jenna was to me and
i feel like i learned a lot from jenna
on how to be a good mentor
and i feel like for those kids i want to
push them to be the best them
and i want to take each of them
individually and figure out how to
work with each of them one by one to
make them better as a group in total
i want to very little i want to make
sure that through these next years they
know
that they're awesome and they're not
going to fall into some of the little
brain traps that i fell into of maybe my
hairline is receding oh maybe i
shouldn't wear this outfit because
maybe i am a baby you know i want i want
to keep them from those traps and i want
to just keep them
happy and keep them working hard and not
let them get burnt out you know keep
them inspired because what they're doing
is incredible
yeah you know it's been a really
transformative year for you jojo i mean
in the beginning you
you let everybody know everything that
you're going through to the show to
going through a breakup how are you
doing have you kind of had a chance to
absorb the smile to feel things
yeah like
how are you doing jojo like how i mean
you know anything
it's interesting when
when i went through my breakup it was
mid-dancing with the stars it was the
week we did disney week and
i didn't really get a chance to feel
anything and then we'd be mid rehearsals
and i would start to feel things but i'd
be like you're fine you're in rehearsals
and then at the end jen would be like
how you doing and i'd just be like
i don't know how i'm doing but i mean
luckily i got this cute little munchkin
so cute like mom i was asleep um no i'm
i'm happy i'm very happy where i'm at in
life right now i'm lucky that i'm busy
yeah you know i i say what i'm grateful
for every day at noon and
i set an alarm on my phone and today i
or yesterday i said i'm grateful to be
busy
and even though working a lot is hard
sometimes i'm grateful because it's
keeping my mind on track and it's
keeping my mind happy and my mind
healthy i love that and finally are you
visiting culture cardi b's daughter you
promised that you were going to visit
her listen the second cardi b message
was me i'm down homegirl hasn't messaged
yet once she does we'll be there how
cool will that be hanging out with cardi
b
i mean so cool honestly just like the
five minute interaction that we had
backstage after the people's choice
awards was just i mean she's so cool
so cool congratulations to the both of
you the show i can't wait for everyone
to watch and mom you are just absolutely
amazing in everything you do so kudos to
you and and just jojo you are such a
great spirit so thank you to both of you
and congratulations
you